diese tiere haben uns alles genommen ich
muss entscheidungen treffen zum besten
der familie
es geht um es zu bekommen das ist der
neue film von george clooney kamen die
mustersiedlung und 200 kapitalistischen
baut auf den verbrechen des wohlstands
für alle und es geht um einen einbruch
um an bord muss draufstehen
wir sind ein haus und es geht um eine
zerrüttete familie und um deren nachbarn
immer nur am rand geht es um diese
nachbarn ist nämlich schwarze die in
dieser siedlung eingezogen sind in der
man vorher stolz drauf war wie divers
wie verschieden mann ist was dann hieß
weiter aus missouri weiße aus georgia
meister aus new york weiße
mittelständler weiße kleinen bürger
kleinbürgerlichen mittelständer und
mittelständische wäscheständer gibt es
fortschritte bei den ermittlungen ein
mafioso verantworten das zeitlich
gesehen
die tücke der sache ist natürlich dass
diese geschichte am rande eigentlich
aufgeregt ist irgendwo sicher auch nach
sie machen es ganz schlaue nämlich sie
zeigen wie krank diese welt die sich
abschottet und die das eben an den rand
verbanden will was nicht ist wie sie
selber im innern dadurch notgedrungene
weise werden mussten das ist diese
familie die im mittelpunkt steht mit
damon ist der patriarch ist heute ein
ganz ganz armes stärke des schiffes des
verkaufs ist die frau die um gebracht
wird und die frau die das überlebt sind
beide schauspieler haben
keine person nahm sowieso ein kredit
wenn sie schulden bei der mafia haben
wäre das eine erklärung dafür was mit
ihrer frau passierte eigentlich reibt
sich dieser film in die anderen clooney
filme also in deren reihe gar nicht so
richtig ein
insofern er sich anfühlt wie eine
erstlings arbeit aber im positiven sinne
etwas freund ich will alles einfach
alles hier ist nach dem stopp auf diese
gefahren der für die paar jahre alt ist
ikone bruder haben es den betrieben
da bringt der blue me so seine editorial
ruhe rein so klein leitartikel der
daraus machen will
das passt wirklich wie die
sprichwörtliche faust aufs
sprichwörtliche auge und das sage ich
nicht nur so daher sondern in diesem
film spritzt das blut hey kumpel und in
einer anderen szene waren sie nicht
beeindruckend ist sind wir unterm bett
und die gewalt findet oben statt wo wir
sie nicht sehen
[Applaus]
und es funktioniert beides wahnsinnig
gut weil er sozusagen will das ding
jeweils ausgesucht hat nach dem was will
ich mit der szene
das heißt es ist autistisch wahnsinnig
gut und inhalt nicht sowieso